nous sommes devant la mairie de le petit
village de 540 habitants près de metz
pour y rencontrer le maire de la ville
hervé censeurs
bonjour
bienvenue à la mairie de
monsieur le maire vous faites partie des
maires qui sont sollicités à quelques
mois de l'élection présidentielle pour
votre précieux parrainage c'est l'une
des conditions pour un candidat on pour
se présenter au scrutin suprême
décrocher 500 parrainages de maires
c'est quelque chose qui vous dérange
vous le problème c'est que ces personnes
là ils viennent nous voir une fois tous
les cinq ans nous dans nos petites
communes on a besoin d'avoir des
personnes qui s'occupent de nos
problèmes de tous les jours et pas
quelqu'un qui vient une fois tous les
cinq ans nous dire voilà nous on a le
meilleur candidat on a si on a ça et ça
dérange beaucoup et puis quand vous
parrainer une personne vous parlez aussi
en contrepartie un parti politique et
quand vous êtes élu dans une petite
commune comme nous de 500 habitants sans
étiquette vous pouvez pas dire
je parraine du pont du rang par rapport
à son parti politique c'est ça va pas
comment ce alors se traduit ce
harcèlement dont parle de très nombreux
maires est ce que c'est le cas de votre
côté ce que vous parlez de harcèlement
déjà vis-à-vis de ses équipes de
campagne de ses futurs éventuels
candidats bon on va dire c'est du
harcèlement mais du petit harcèlement
parce que les gens ils nous appellent
soit par téléphone soit ils nous
envoient des mails où il se déplace en
mairie ils ont envoyé des jeunes des
personnes pour venir avec leurs
documents pour expliquer leur programme
ils veulent que vous les parrainer que
vous signez leur leur bulletin de
parrainage mais voilà j'en ai eu l'autre
fois et on l'a pas fait vous montrez le
genre de mails que vous recevez donc là
où c'est un parrainage de monsieur
vincent de la vie et ils l'annoncent
bien
à monsieur hervé sincère merdo le muc
donc il nous met tout son programme et
si on veut on peut répondre en signant
le parrainage j'en ai reçu un hôte par
exemple de monsieur jean lassalle bon il
lui ça fait déjà plusieurs fois qui se
présente est pareil mais tous au
programme et après vous pouvez donc on
peut cliquer puisse mettre je souhaite
parrainer jean lassalle est ce qu'ils
vous font des promesses ces futurs
candidats vous dites il ne pense qu'à
nous une fois tous les cinq ans mais ils
vous promettent des choses au moment où
ils vous démarche je pense qu'ils sont
comme tous nos grands politiques ils
promettent des choses avant élection dès
que les élections sont arrivés et qu'ils
sont élus à pleyben vous pouvez pas
faire toujours ce que vous proposez ou
ce que vous souhaitez parce que il ya ce
qui gère la france est aussi l'argent et
puis beaucoup d'autres choses c'est
l'europe donc on peut avoir des idées
mais on peut pas toujours les mettre en
avant on y va oui
cette condition des 500 parrainages de
maires ou d'élus vous diriez que c'est
en plus que c'est un mois qu'il faudrait
la conserver ou la retirer pour moi il
faudrait la supprimer carrément parce
que les petits candidats comme vous et
moi donc on n'aura jamais nos 500
signatures donc il en faudrait beaucoup
moins parce que vous vous n'avez pas les
mêmes idées qu'un grand candidat donc
vous pouvez pas tout le monde peut pas
vous soutenir et puis on a chaque merab
a le droit à un parrainage peut pas
parler n'est plusieurs candidats donc
encore monsieur le maire vous avez
parrainer un candidat en 2012 et depuis
vous le regrettez vous nous dites plus
jamais pourquoi ben parce que quand vous
parrainez un candidat les personnes du
village qui pensent que vous parrainez
un parti politique et nous dans nos
petites communes on est élu sans parti
politique et monnaies qui punit cipal ne
voudrais pas qu'on parle de partis de
droite de gauche de n'importe quelle
partie parce qu'après on vous met une
étiquette sur le dos et on pense que
vous avez que vous votez ce parti on va
dire c'était quelques l étiquette quel
genre de partie c'était un parti
d'extrême le destin de droite à l'époque
donc voila et vous faites une fois une
erreur dans votre vie vous la fait pas
d'eux quels ont été les retours des
habitants qu'est ce qu'on vous a dit ben
il ya quelques habitants qui pensaient
que je voter
l'extrême droite et pourtant c'était pas
le cas donc voilà donc après on dans nos
petites communes il faut pas parler
politique autrement vous êtes mort on va
dire